et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quel autre firme française peut
prétendre atteindre l'aura de citroën
fondée en 1919 par andré citroën
elle a définitivement marqué l'histoire
de l'automobile de sa créativité et de
la singularité de ses productions de ses
exploits unique à ses recherches
technologiques
voici donc laventure de citroën placée
sous le signe de l'innovation depuis
déjà 80 ans et pour longtemps encore
[Musique]
tout partira de l'imagination de sept
membres et citroën
génial visionnaire d'un dynamisme et
d'une force morale incroyable il va
révolutionner en france et en europe
l'automobile l'industrie et la publicité
[Musique]
la marque citroën avait comme créateur
un homme qui s'appelait citroën et c'est
lui justement qui avait les idées qu'ils
avaient envie ne pas faire comme tout le
monde qui avait envie d'innover mais à
tout propos pour l'automobile bien sûr
mais pour bien d'autres choses sur bien
d'autres sujets c'était un créateur et
un inventif andré citroën il ne faut pas
l'oublier avait fabriqué des obus les
hobbits 75 à une cadence extraordinaire
il en sortait des dizaines de milliers
par jour
alors quand en 1919 il a transformé son
industrie d'obus en industrie automobile
tout de suite c'était l'idée de la
grande série il a eu des contacts avec
henry ford et il s'en est sorti renforcé
parce que henry ford lui déjà sortait
depuis plusieurs années l'effort de thé
en série et puis crée une usine avec un
personnel compétent bien sûr mais qui
aime son travail il ne pouvait
travailler qu'avec des gens qui aimaient
ça
[Musique]
il a créé une véritable sécurité sociale
pour son personnel ce qui n'existait
nulle part ailleurs
il a trahi aussi une aide pour les
femmes enceintes
il a beaucoup beaucoup participé ou
bien-être de son personnes
et partant d'améliorer s'en aller les
conditions de votre existence aux usines
je suis heureux de profiter de cette
circonstance pour vous informer que la
fesse de l'arbre de noël
il vous permet à tous de nous réunir et
de distraire les enfants de 6 à 12 ans
aura lieu le 27 décembre au palais des
sports
il y aura comme d'habitude
représentation distribution jouer goûter
tombola et que le nombre de places étant
de 17000 tous les enfants et tous leurs
parents pour hanter heymans y trouver
réunissent bonnafé team cher ami et vib
la bonne humeur française
afin d'affirmer sa popularité andré
citroën ira jusqu'à créer des compagnies
de bus et de taxi et installer le
premier réseau de signalisation routière
qui aurait pu imaginer pourtant que la
construction d'obus et de chevron qui
feront le cycle de sa marque
le conduirait à la production
d'automobiles en 1919
andré citroën a décidé de se lancer dans
la fabrication automobile
il y pensait déjà depuis un moment il
avait il était représentant directeur
général même des automobiles morse
quelques des voitures très conventionnel
mais qui ne lui convenait pas par contre
lui il pensait surtout après les
contacts avec ford fait une voiture
populaire pas cher et tout équipé ça a
été la tipp à la première de toutes les
citroën c'est une voiture assez
classique sur le plan technique mais
elle avait tout de même eu un carter
moteur des carter de boîte de vitesses
etc en alliage léger
ça c'était quand même important
[Musique]
en 1925 citroën sur une voiture qui
était la suite de la série à et de la
série b et l abbé 14 et elle avait un
moteur tout à fait nouveau parce que le
bloc cylindres avec ces trous dedans
recevait dans chaque cas les âges
chaque cil 1 un appareil qui descendait
cet appareil avait des galets
cylindrique tout autour de l' axe
principal et ses galets pouvait
s'écarter par un excentrique qu'il y
avait dans le milieu alors on descendait
ce chapelet de galets dans le cylindre
et on écartait les galets qui venait
écrasé le l'intérieur du cylindre avec
une précision étonnante à quel point que
les cylindres était fabriqué plus petit
que la dé la cote définitive puisque on
l'élargît c'est ça donnait une dureté à
ses cylindres extraordinaire il était
inusable et le procédé malheureusement
été abandonnées parce qu'ils étaient
trop chers toujours dans l'idée de faire
parler lui de faire parler d'une onde
citroën cet homme génial a décidé de
fabriquer des auto show avec tricherie
l'aide d'un grand ingénieur instinct et
grèce qui est drôle c'est le nom qui est
resté de ces chenilles en caoutchouc
ce qui était tout à fait nouveau et puis
ça a été la création de la croisière
noire et finalement de la croisière
jaune et tout ça a été une époque qui a
coûté très cher à citroën
il a essayé d'en vendre en france à
l'industrie pour remplacer les tracteurs
agricoles 7 et cher les fumis était
relativement fragile les réparations
presque impossible et il n'y a pas le
dessus
dans les années 20 et 30 citroën va
aller d'invention en inventions à tous
les niveaux il est par exemple le
premier édité des revues techniques sur
ces modèles concernant ces véhicules
andré citroën toujours à la recherche
d'un meilleur confort adopte en 1932 un
brevet français vendus à chrysler le
moteur flottant qui consiste à monter la
mécanique sur silembloc bien avant en
1925 il décide de renforcer la sécurité
de l'habitacle et utilise la coque tout
acier
auparavant la carrosserie était
constitué d'une structure en bois à
panneaux de tôle qui ne pouvait résister
à aucun choc
l'utilisation exclusive d'acier
constitue alors une grande innovation
pour la sécurité routière
[Musique]
oh
m
à
oh
[Musique]
poursuivant dans ce sens la marque
citroën lance en 1932 avec la nouvelle
gamme rosalie la carrosserie monopièce
il ne s'agit pas encore d'une structure
véritablement monocoque mais l'ensemble
des panneaux latéraux sont pressés d'une
seule pièce ce qui constitue une
formidable innovation dans le domaine de
l'emboutissage la rigidité de la
carrosserie s'en trouve évidemment
accrue et citroën n'hésitent pas à
effectuer des démonstrations
spectaculaires pour le prouver
oh
[Musique]
de telle invention s'accompagne
logiquement de coûts de production plus
élevés les techniques de fabrication et
les machines outils étant de plus en
plus perfectionnés malgré le succès
considérable de ces automobiles andré
citroën sans dette d'année en année pour
améliorer sans cesse les effets de la
crise économique de 1929 commence
néanmoins à avoir des répercussions
dramatiques sur l'ensemble de
l'industrie en 1932 la production chute
de moitié et citroën est contraint de
licencier massivement et d'effectuer des
contrôles draconiens sur les finances ce
qui n'empêche pas d'agrandir à grands
frais
le site de javel en 1933 emporté par un
enthousiasme et une mégalomanie aveugle
continuellement animés par l'envié
d'aller toujours plus loin dans
l'innovation est d'avoir plusieurs
longueurs d'avancé sur la concurrence
citroën lance en 1933 contre l'avis des
financiers
l'étude d'une automobile révolutionnaire
à tous points de vue
[Musique]
citroën pensez déjà depuis un moment
faire une traction avant
et voilà que lefebvre arrive avec ce
projet ça l'accord a été conclu tout de
suite et un an après vous me suivez bien
de mars 1933 mars 1934
l'attraction était finie elle roulait et
elle était présenté aux concessionnaires
en partant de zéro
aucune autre pièce d'aucun autre modèle
de citroën avait été réutilisés qu'on
serait incapable de faire en partant de
zéro
une voiture aussi révolutionnaire que
celle là on serait incapable de le faire
maintenant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tout va bien la promenade continue
je
alors cette traction avant avec
carrosserie coque ce qui était nouveau
elle avait un plancher plat lis donc
aérodynamique
elle avait d'une suspension par bordeaux
torsion elle avait un tableau de bord
nouveau les vitesses sur la planche de
bord à l'avant de cette coque
il y avait quatre broches avec quatre
boulons et on pouvait enlever le mans en
enlevant les quatre boulons enlever tout
le train avant d'un bloc le moteur la
boîte de vitesses les cieux l'ayroule
radiateur tous sortaient d'un bloc comme
un tiroir et puis et puis et puis ça a
été le succès de la traction avant
[Musique]
andré citroën ne connaîtra pourtant pas
le succès considérable de sa traction
avant rongé par un cancer usé
psychologiquement il décède le 3 juillet
1935 à l'âge de 57 ans laissant derrière
lui une oeuvre considérable pas
seulement liée à l'histoire de
l'automobile
il est mort une et parce que il a pris
les banquiers de frau et il est un peu
mégalo ça va le personnage dont il n'a
jamais accepté d'être les bitters des
banques et de devoirs tous les lundis
matin comme tous les présidents y
compris celles d'automobiles aller faire
leurs courses verte devant les banquiers
il est même allé jusqu'à créer sa propre
banque
en faisant ses propres crédits parce
qu'il a aussi inventé de crédit
automobile et la l'intelligentzia de la
banque s'est braquée contre lui et elle
a mis en faillite mais d'une feuille
d'ailleurs qui qui était à la limite de
la tolérance tolérable puisque à trois
mois après elle faisait la soudure
il avait pris du retard sur le lancement
de la traction si l'attraction était
arrivée la maison se redressait elle
s'est redressée d'ailleurs quelques mois
après lui je pense qu'un bon citoyen a
tout inventé de la publicité de la
publicité menées 1
certes il est arrivé à l'âge de la
réclame c'était encore dubo dubon
dubonnet
et avec cet esprit d'innovation mais
aussi d'aventuriers qui levante il a
défriché tous ceux qui étaient autour de
la publicité
d'abord les croisières qui l'ont rendu
célèbre mais quitter des véritables
opérations publicité la visite cuisine
lindbergh lui même qui s'est dirigé
grâce à la tour eiffel qui atterrit
grâce à la tour eiffel et citroën si on
était en fait elle est venue à cause de
ça parce qu'il avait refusé
mais comme il a estimé que
la tour eiffel illuminée par citoyen qui
avait sauvé la vie il a accepté de venir
inaugurer le lusine cette extraordinaire
et puis il a inventé ce qui fait florès
encore aujourd'hui les essais l'avait
prévu le principe de caravanes qui
faisaient le tour de france de toutes
ces concessions et qui pour la première
fois permettait laisser les voitures qui
bong 70 ans était une révolution en 1922
andré citroën va lancer ses fameux raid
à travers l'afrique et l'asie la
traversée du sahara en 1922 et 1923 puis
la fameuse croisière noire en 1924 et
1925 vont constituer un fantastique défi
technique et humain permettre d'explorer
des terres encore méconnue et apporter à
citroën
une publicité sans précédent
[Musique]
plus emblématiques encore sera la
croisière jaune de 1931 et 1932 avec un
parcours de 12 mille kilomètres à
travers des paysages qui n'avait encore
jamais vu d'automobiles et n'en verront
jamais plus la syrie l'irak
l'afghanistan l'inde verront passer la
colonne de citroën les autos chenille
passeront même à travers les plus hauts
sommets du tibet bien qu'il ait fallu
parfois les démonter pièce par pièce
puis ce seront les vents de sable du
désert de gobi qui attendront les
aventuriers français l'arrivée
triomphale à pékin consacrera
l'endurance des mécaniques citroën douze
des treize autochenille ayant pris le
départ
franchissant les portes de la capitale
chinoise
[Musique]
les films réalisés sur ces croisières
feront le tour du monde
faisant du nom citroën un synonyme
d'avant garde et de défis
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en 1925 andré citroën aura une autre
idée pour faire connaître sa marque
toujours grandiloquent il n'hésitera pas
en effet à investir toute la hauteur de
la tour eiffel pour y installer son nom
en lettres de feu des milliers
d'ampoulés de mètres de câbles
électriques seront nécessaires pour
parvenir à créer cette publicité géant
pour mener à bien l'installation fera
appel à des voltigeurs trapézistes et
autres cascadeur capable de travailler à
plusieurs dizaines de mètres du sol sans
connaître le vertige on remarquera
d'ailleurs sur ces images qu'aucun d'eux
ne porte de baudriers ou de câbles de
sécurité
[Musique]
ans
m
une aiguille chevaux citroën de série
petite rosalie a parcouru sur
l'autodrome de montlhéry à plus de 93 de
moyenne 300 mille kilomètres en 130 4
jours ce qui représente près des quatre
cinquièmes de la distance de la terre à
la lune jamais voiture au monde d' avait
approché une telle performance
les huit chevaux citroën petite rosalie
a été acheté chez un concessionnaire
parisien de la marque par la société d
huile yako et mise en piste par l le 15
mars 1933
la voici au 62e jour de sa ronde qui
jusqu'àlors s'est déroulée sans histoire
à cette date elle commence à établir de
nouveaux records du monde puisqu'elle
vient d'atteindre 140 mille kilomètres
et le surpasser par conséquent l'exploit
de son aîné voici devant la ligne de
départ le poste de contrôle où se
tiennent en permanence jour et nuit
les commissaires techniques et
chronométreur officiel de la sienne la
tentative est contrôlée d'une façon
permanente par les commissaires
techniques de l'automobile club de
france qui veille impitoyablement à la
stricte application des règlements
internationaux
mais voici l'heure du ravitaillement de
la voiture celui ci ne peut
naturellement s'effectuer qu'en présence
même d'un commissaire régulièrement
toutes les cinq heures la voiture fait
son plein d'essence et éventuellement
d'huile et d'eau c'est aussi à ce moment
que s'effectue le changement de pilote
le signal d'arrêt est donné voici bons
échos qui va relayer au volant de la
vaillante petite voiture son camarade
justin marchand les ravitaillements sont
effectués à une allure record car les
temps d'arrêt quels que soient leur
cause ne sont en aucun cas neutraliser
leur durée compte dans le temps total du
parcours de la performante
la pompe à essence un débit beaucoup
trop lent et remplacé par un réservoir
dans lequel le carburant est maintenu
sous forte pression
grâce à une bouteille d'air comprimé le
plein d'huile est effectué sous la
surveillance du commissaire il replonge
ensuite l'orifice de remplissage du
moteur
toujours sous ses yeux on procède à la
vérification de la pression des pneus et
le cas échéant ou quelques travaux
d'entretien autorisée qui ne peuvent
être effectuée qu'au poste de
ravitaillement et avec les seuls moyens
du bord
[Musique]
est ce une concurrente étrangère la
forme valentine qui n'est certes pas
d'un modèle des plus récents patel
s'attaquer au record de petite rosalie
non elle vient simplement faire sa
promenade quotidienne pour semer les 125
lantern tempête qui jalonneront la nuit
le bas côté de la piste
[Musique]
la vente se poursuit inlassablement et
juin succède au jour et les records en
records
27 juillet petite rosalie ayant parcouru
la formidable distance de 300 mille
kilomètres en 130 4 jours monsieur
citroën décidé de l'arrêter avant que
l'usure ou un accident fortuit de la met
hors de course
désirant que l'examen détaillé de ces
divers organes permettent de faire le
point des progrès accomplis en vue de
préparer les progrès à venir
[Musique]
en quelques mots monsieur citera une
remercie tous ceux qui ont collaboré à
cette extraordinaire performance tout
particulièrement monsieur dintilhac
administrateur délégué de la société d
huile yako en moteur de la tentative et
la merveilleuse équipe de pilotes
conduit par césar marchand l'homme des
records du monde afin de stimuler les
recherches des ingénieurs en vue de
nouveaux progrès à réaliser
monsieur citroën termine son allocution
en annonçant qu'il vient de décider
d'offrir un prix de 3 millions aux
constructeurs français ou étrangers qui
avant le 1er janvier 1935 réalisera le
premier avec une voiture de sa
fabrication
une performance meilleure que celle
établie par petite rosalie à la fin du
lunch qui termine la manifestation petit
rosalie fait un dernier tour de piste
piloté par monsieur andré citroën lui
même
[Musique]
mais tout n'était pas fini pour petite
rosalie son capot est soigneusement
plombé par un commissaire
[Musique]
puis elle qui plateau drôme pour se
rendre au laboratoire de l'acf toujours
suivi d'assez contrôleurs
le directeur du laboratoire monsieur lui
mais vérifie lui même la cylindrée de
petites rosen
quelques jours après il se rend aux
usines citroën pour choisir au hasard
sur la chaîne de montage un chat séduit
chevaux afin de s'assurer par l'examen
comparatif des organes des deux châssis
que petite rosalie est bien de série
[Musique]
toutes les cotes des pièces sont
comparés
leur identité est encore contrôlée par
la comparaison de leur pouvoir
[Musique]
on va
les opérations terminées les pièces de
chaque châssis sont enfermés dans deux
caisses soigneusement repérer les blonds
b
[Musique]
elles sont transportées au laboratoire
des arts et métiers où une commission
composée des plus éminentes
personnalités scientifiques françaises
examinent en détails les pièces
d'homologues et constate la parfaite
identité au point de vue chimique et
métal nos graphiques petit trot à
remonter fini sa carrière sur le stand
du salon de l'automobile la poule va la
demi heure puis et puis transféré au
palais des expositions citroën place de
l'europe avec ses devanciers
s il avait fallu trente ans à
l'industrie automobile pour porter le
record du monde de distance à 50 mille
km2 en suffire aux usines citroën pour
les levées progressivement à 300 mille
kilomètres et cela avec des voitures
strictement de série aucune marque au
monde ne peut produire un tel témoignage
la qualité de fabrication
[Musique]
oh
rhett internationaux record publicité
andré citroën aura révolutionné les
méthodes de communication des grandes
entreprises
après sa mort il faudra attendre la fin
des années 50 et l'arrivée du studio
delpire pour retrouver des publicités
citroën novatrice dans les années
soixante dix la collaboration avec le
publiciste jacques séguéla perpétuera
une certaines innovations dans ce
domaine
[Musique]
et approche des sites web par le tour du
monde parce que c'est eux qui m'avait
permis de populariser manteau demande
c'est eux qui m'ont fait écrire mon
premier livre c'est grâce à lui que je
suis rentré un match plein qui vont
faire un prêt à paris match où je
faisais d'ailleurs j'ai payé le
lancement de dents match de la cx et de
beaucoup de modèles citroën
et puis c'est ensuite qu'ils m'ont fait
rentrer dans la publicité chez delpire
puis j'ai créé mon agence d el firma
d'ailleurs vendu la sienne à ce
moment-là y est c'est comme ça que je
suis entré directement sur le budget
site web pour une fois en main propre
c'est parti de là était toujours au
niveau de la marque est parti avec
savignac puis ensuite avec jean paul
goude iration et tout ce qui s'est passé
par la suite
[Musique]
la capacité à produire des publicités
originales étaient bien évidemment
renforcée par le fait que les citroën
étaient des autos d'avangard après
guerre la deux chevaux puis la ds vont
en effet maintenir avec brio la
politique d'innovation de la marque
française
[Musique]
amari le 35e salon de l'automobile a été
inaugurée par monsieur vincent auriol
président de la république dans la
première visite a été pour ceux qui
comme fram est sans devenu par leurs
luxueuses conception de la carrosserie
les grands couturiers de la voiture
il est loin le temps où le poète parlait
de ces machines qui permettait
d'absorber en un jour autant de paysages
de ciel et de spectable qu'en absorber
autrefois au bourg de toute une vie le
temps où loin des remises et des gares
loin des ateliers secourable
l'automobiliste était à la merci des
caprices d'une force mystérieuse qui
nous laisse est inquiet sur l'avenir de
la géniale découverte de l'homme
une véritable révolution été provoqué
dans le domaine du véhicule économique
par citroën qui présente un modèle de
conception pour le moins originale
peut-être verrons-nous demain ces
véhicules circuler sur nos routes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
hélas deux shoah a pris naissance en
prototype en 1935 alors il ya eu tout
sur l'aide au chaud il ya eu des
monocylindres débit s'il à la fois
distant barreaux à refroidissement par
air il ya eu de tout des moteurs deux
temps
tout a été essayé la carrosserie a été
parce qu'on voulait gagner du poids elle
a été faite en toile cirée tendue sur
des arceaux métalliques toujours pour
gagner du poids et une voiture qui
devait très économique et qui devraient
pouvoir passer la nuit dans un champ
comme un tracteur où elle devait être
sans entretien
et puis la guerre est arrivée le bureau
d'études citroën a continué de
travailler quand même sur sa deux shows
mais elle avait pas de batterie pas de
batterie pas d'entretien il y avait un
lanceur à main et puis il ya eu un
lanceur api avec une et puis
c'était pas pratique du tout cette
voiture qui était parfaitement viable en
campagne avait un grave inconvénient
elle ne pouvait pas se passionner la
nuit en ville parce qu'à l'époque le
code de la route qui était beaucoup plus
sévère que maintenant sur ce cas précis
les voitures est clair en ville la nuit
devaient être éclairé un possible
d'éclairer une voiture sans batterie
paraît pas mettre une pile de clan alors
à un ingénieur du bureau d'études
c'est vous dire si ce bureau d'études
était éclectique il s'était beaucoup
intéressé aux insectes ou trois fois et
il a eu l'idée d'élever des vers
luisants on se disant je vais extraire
de cet insecte sa partie phosphorescente
je vais en faire un agglomérat on mettra
ça dans des petites boules qui sont
placés de chaque côté de la deux shows
comme ça la nuit
elle sera éclairée alors il a élevé des
vers luisants mais malheureusement ce
pauvre bête quand elle était morte ne
lui fait plus vive et s'est arrêté là et
puis là deux fois à continuer avec cette
fois ci une batterie à laval avait une
suspension par ressort placés
latéralement et cette suspension avait
une particularité c'est qu'elle elle
était un interactions c'est à dire si
une roue avant se soulevait ou passant
sur un obstacle sur une pierre est bien
là suspense
faisait réagir la roue arrière du même
côté et la faisait dressé pour maintenir
la carrosserie et puis et puis et puis
elle consommait très peu elle craignait
pas le gel elle était elle est devenue
la voiture populaire des français et
avec des délais de livraison qui ont
atteint 7,1 même presque huit ans
tellement tout le monde la demande
[Musique]
la deux chevaux en effet devenir la plus
populaire des voitures françaises
séduisent ont aussi bien le paysan que
la jeune bourgeoise éprise de liberté en
haut de la gamme
l'attraction se fait alors vieillissante
et son remplacement devient impératif au
milieu des années 50 elle va laisser
place à la plus formidable vitrine
technologique jamais produite
la ds
[Musique]
la plus grande innovation de cette
nouvelle berline sera constitué par
l'utilisation massive de l'hydraulique
déjà testé sur l'attraction 15 h
aux êtres vivants on a emprunté le
mécanisme circulatoire pulsations du
coeur pression constante dans les
artères cette fonction vitale est
assurée par un système central la pompe
l'accumulateur le réservoir maintiennent
sous pression constante l'huile en
circulation ce coeur mécanique est relié
au bloc de suspension de chaque roue qui
comprend une paire ni gaz ni ville un
piston solidaire dollar ou un bras de
levier actionnant le clapet du
correcteur de hauteur véritable verrou
qui commande les relations entre circuit
centrale espère silo charles la voiture
le piston comprime le garde lui sous
pression libéré par le clapet pénètre
dans la sphère et repousse le fiston la
voiture revient donc doucement à son
niveau
quel que soit le point chargé le même
phénomène se produit le coeur mécanique
permet donc à la voiture de retrouver sa
ligne de flottaison hauteur constante au
dessus du sol
ils ont des charges de la voiture le gaz
comprimé se détend l'expédier il
retourne au réservoir la voiture revient
à son niveau
les bottes et les petits carreaux
n'appuierait pas le clapet du correcteur
de hauteur dans les sphères un
dispositif de laminage anor et les
mouvements de l'huile
les balancements parasites les plongées
brusques sur coup de frein sont éliminés
par le durcissement automatique des
trains avant ou arrière si la suspension
hydropneumatique à supprimer tous les
éléments métalliques de la suspension
platine cette géniale combinaison de
l'air et des fluides
on la doit à l'ingénieur autodidacte
paul majid ce qu'il adaptera tous les
organes principaux de la déesse
suspension mais aussi direction
transmission et freinage seront ainsi
gérés par ce principe de l'hydraulique
assurant un confort et une sécurité de
conduite encore jamais atteint jusque là
[Musique]
le père de la ds est le même que celui
de la traction et de la deux chevaux
andré lefebvre ingénieur de génie
peut-être le plus important de
l'histoire de l'automobile fut recruté
par andré citroën en 1933 pendant plus
de vingt ans c'est à lui et à son équipe
que l'on devra cette incessante course à
l'innovation une volonté avant gardiste
qui fera prendre à la marque au double
chevron
près de vingt ans d'avancé sur la
concurrence
jamais un bureau d'étude n'aura fournit
autant d'idées nouvelles et de progrès
techniques sur des automobiles de grande
série
[Musique]
une innovation que l'on retrouvera
jusque dans le stylisme grâce à des
designers formidablement inspiré tels
que flaminio bertoni bien sûr mais aussi
son successeur robert opron petit feu
des jeux pas la force du bureau d'études
de sites web
on mettait tout notre savoir protano si
on avait une volonté pour que la voiture
existe en fait je pense que citroën
n'avait pas besoin de faire des dribbles
car pour démontrer qu'il avait un bureau
d'études il fallait mieux que ce soit
fait pour les voitures de série la
confrontation de tende esprit inventif
ne se faisait pourtant pas toujours dans
la douceur
j'avoue qu'au départ je n'étais pas sûr
de bien m'entendre avec bertoni qu'ils
avaient été d'une cours de cet entretien
ses as pas violent mais presque
on avait balancé mes dessins par terre
c'est vrai ça et je lui avais demandé de
molay ramasser et il m'avait dit lumière
de la fin de l'entretien mais vous
pourriez m'intéressait je dis peut-être
mais vous vous ne m'intéressait pas les
deux hommes ont pourtant collaborer et
leur premier travail sera de restyler la
ds si possible en innovant encore le
projet de bertoli qui avaient un projet
fait très rapidement
ne tenez pas compte des encombrements
des optiques et une certaine finesse
naturel si vous voulez quand il a fallu
monter le gros fabre 180 plus le phares
additionnels de 135 je crois il a fallu
échancrée terriblement 7
cette ouverture et majid sombre gars
d'en faire un jeu où on me dit même si
tu pouvais encore gagner un petit peu
ici tu vois on pourrait peut-être faire
tourner le petit phare effet ce que j'ai
fait et ma jeunesse
avec son génie coutume millet avec
handicap de vélo fait moins trois fois
non il a dit sa fille
[Musique]
m
on
[Musique]
à la fin des années 60 citroën va leur
faire feu de tout bois et développer de
nouvelles techniques et concepts tels
que la méhari un véhicule de loisirs à
carrosserie en plastique sur plateforme
de chevaux puis viendra la gs une
berline moyenne gamme résultant de
grandes recherches aérodynamiques
hommage sc un véhicule avec une faible
motorisation qui doit avoir un bon
scénique la prouesse est donc nous
partons recherche très très rapidement
la tulle donc ça a été un succès c'était
un succès parce que l'on a eu le prix de
la voiture de l'année on a eu le prix de
style car sa ligne chat comme ça à
l'époque
[Musique]
sur le plan technique le début des
années 70 c'est marqué par l'étude des
moteurs à pistons rotatifs suivant le
principe du docteur winkle deux modèles
produits en petites séries
la m35 puis la gs birotor verront le
jour
mais la crise pétrolière et divers
problèmes de fiabilisation viendront à
bout du projet entre-temps citroën aura
également produit le plus fantastique
coupé de grand tourisme français l'asm
il ya d'abord eu une ambiguïté mais un
désaccord
un désaccord entre eux n'est et moi né
voulait un véhicule de rallye très court
et très très agressif et très sportif et
réfléchissante veiller davantage à un
véhicule de prestige en tourisme qui
apporterait une image à la marque très
forte d'autant plus que la ds vie
secteur je m'en suis expliqué avec bien
berthod qui était tout à fait d'accord
avec toi
[Applaudissements]
au milieu des années 70 la gamme citroën
et la plus originale du monde
néanmoins la ds accuse le poids des
années et doit être remplacé petit à
coup on s'est orienté donc dans une
voiture qui ne délivrait pas de la ds
mais qui garderait dans l'esprit les
mêmes méthodes de travail c'est-à-dire
le cmx le sf suspension messe avec son
double commande avec son châssis
indépendant de la carrosserie monté sur
six langues d'oc et a donc toujours
cette volonté de progresser dans le
confort dans la tenue de route en
silence dans l'absence de vibrations
dans le bon cx extracteur lagesse
existants je me suis dit après tout
pourquoi ne pas constituer une gamme
[Musique]
dans le même profil de voiture c'est à
dire le peuple passé au tri corps bien
que monsieur hamel tenait absolument à
ce qu'on fasse une 404 104 donc sont
venus voir nos projets ont d'abord ce
fameux tri corps d'armand et raven elle
était ravie vous voyez que l'on trouve
quand on cherche on trouve
j'ai dit oui l'on trouve ça dépend de ce
qu'on cherche
monsieur bercot était pas loin et il
boudait je sentais que c'était pas son
truc alors je me suis retrouvé un moment
à côté de lui et je lui ai dit vous
savez j'ai une étude en parallèle mais
on avait notre système de cloisons j'ai
vu des photos accordéon jeu les anglais
voir
la cites avant il était ravi il a appelé
tous les lundis perdez pas votre temps
là parce qu'il faut faire et la censure
est intervenue mais par contre celui de
ravenel était pas il était persuadé
qu'en faisant des peugeot
sa démarche est en effet sous contrôle
michelin depuis 1935 citroën est racheté
par peugeot en 1974 si la ln et la visa
ne seront que des sochaliens de
maquiller boudé par les vrais citroên i
si j'étais resté avec eux c'est eux qui
m'ont foutu à la porte parce que je
n'aurais jamais accepté de faire une vie
date pas possible il n'y a pas eu
d'évolution c'est rétrograde plutôt la
faute n'incombe pas nécessairement
seulement un peu jour peugeot part d'un
sentiment très clair très net il faut
faire de l'argent le président en est un
c'est un banquier à partir de là il est
facile de comprendre qu'il va se passer
point de vue de la banque d'organes mais
quelques gens que je citerai n'est pas
parler d'elle même même falconnet
falconnet digne un moment là deux shows
et irremplaçable donc elle ne sera pas
remplacée
c'est très simple il faut il faut
toujours aller plus vite avec plus de
sécurité plus de confort et selon la
gamme avec des prix comme là deux choses
justes vous aligner ces paramètres
ils sont éternels et vous progressez
vous posez vous toujours cette question
d'automobiles profitera alors à partir
du moment où se pose plus ces questions
où la seule question c'est combien gagne
tout le reste devient secondaire est en
fait le lavaux la voiture la meilleure
c'est celle du concurrent moins cher on
modifie pas du jour au lendemain une
marque qui s'est créée autour d' de
l'innovation s'est produit vers la fin
des années 80 après plusieurs années de
vaches maigres
citroën va pourtant entamé une phase de
réveil et retrouver la voie de
l'innovation
les prototypes activa est active à deux
vont ainsi renouer avec la grande
tradition de la firme au double chevron
celle de proposer le meilleur confort et
la plus grande sécurité de conduite
possible outre les quatre roues
directionnelles et les diverses
opérations géré électroniquement comme
l'abaissement de la garde au sol à haute
vitesse c'est avant tout la suspension
active à qui retient l'attention
héritière directe de la suspension
oléopneumatique de paul pagès
elle en est l'évolution est la
quintessence
elle se compose d'un circuit hydraulique
radicalement simplifié de 6 faire d'une
conception entièrement nouvelle
et d'un bloc hydro électronique intégré
ultra compact appelé b achi le bloc b h
i reçoit via un réseau multiplexé les
informations gérées au centième de
seconde sur la vitesse du véhicule
l'intensité d accélération ou
décélération
de nouveaux capteurs spécifiques
l'informent de plus sur les débattements
deux roues l'angle de braquage et la
vitesse de rotation du volant
ainsi informés en permanence le bloc b à
shiva gérer en temps réel le
comportement du véhicule
la troisième sphère présente sur chaque
essieu selon qu'elle sera mise en
circuit ou hors circuit permettra en
faisant varier simultanément la
flexibilité et l'amortissement
d'exploiter deux état de fonctionnement
souple ou faire comme pour confirmer le
renouveau de citroën les prototypes se
sont multipliés à la fin des années 90
divers concepts car issu du bureau
d'études comme la majestueuse berline
lignage c6 emprunte aux autos des
grandeurs comme la ds ou la cx
à noter pour les amateurs que la ligne
âge préfigurerait la prochaine grande
berline offerte par citroën en l'an 2000
[Musique]
je prends
les nouvelles idées ne manquent pas non
plus pour les véhicules de loisirs comme
en témoigne la plurielle à la
carrosserie modulable permettant de
transformer un petit monospace en
cabriolet
[Musique]
citons encore l'osmose défi idéologique
puisqu'il envisage de réconcilier les
automobilistes avec les piétons à paris
irène épaules dans leur osmose
destination saint cloud d'ailleurs c'est
écrit ils sont prêts à partager la route
et ils le font savoir
jean est un piéton qui cherchent une
osmose pour aller à saint cloud paul a
perçu le message il va le prendre en
charge
[Musique]
chacun vit sa vie
mais la route est partagé
[Musique]
il faut bien l'avouer je n'aurais jamais
dit à 5 ans quand la nouvelle vague
n'était pas monté un de maintenant
qu'elle est là on peut lire on a connu
dix ans de faiblesse est produit et
fatalement ça s'est reportée sur la
marque et quels qu'aient pu être les
circonvolutions qu'on a fait en
publicité elle seule n'aurait pas
suffire à lever la marque mais déjà est
arrivé
la xsara qui est une belle voiture qui a
représenté le redémarrage de la beauté
et de l'élégance du raffinement français
il ya du catherine deneuve d'un site web
à partir d'aujourd'hui tous les ans un
nouveau modèle va sortir tous les ans
une nouvelle bombe va arriver et
citoyenne produit un citoyen et le
public le sent déjà on le voit déjà dans
les études d'image et les français
beaucoup de patience en tout pardonné à
cette marque parce qu'ils ont espéré et
cru en a marre
essayons de partager ce bel optimisme
espérons que pour fêter son centenaire
en 2019 citroën sera une marque plus que
jamais présent est synonyme d'innovation
la dernière berline c5 à la ligne
élégante mais conventionnelle fait
aujourd'hui partie des automobiles les
plus sûres et les plus confortablement
que peut-on imaginer de plus que citroën
réalisent une bombe aussi exceptionnel
que fut la ds il y a plus de 50 ans
[Musique]
vous n'imaginez pas tous que c'est trop
et ne peut faire pour vous
lui qui pensait surtout après les
contacts avec ford faire une voiture
populaire pas cher et tout équipé ça a
été la tipp à la première de toutes les
sites revel c'est une voiture assez
classique sur le plan technique mais
elle avait tout de même eu un carter
moteur des carter de boîte de vitesses
etc en alliage léger
ça c'était quand même important
[Musique]
en 1925 citroën sur une voiture qui
était la suite de la série à et de la
série b était la d14 et elle avait un
moteur tout à fait nouveau parce que le
bloc cylindres avec ces trous dedans
recevait dans chaque à les âges
chaque cil 1 un appareil qui descendait
cet appareil avait des galets
cylindrique tout autour de l'axé
principal et ses galets pouvait
s'écarter par un excentrique qu'il y
avait dans le milieu alors on descendait
ce chapelet de galets dans le cylindre
et on écartait les galets qui venait
écrasé le l'intérieur du cylindre avec
une précision étonnante à quel point que
les cylindres était fabriqué plus petit
que la dé la côte définitive puisque on
l'élargît c'est ça donnait une dureté à
six cylindres extraordinaire il était
inusable et le procédé malheureusement
été abandonnées parce qu'ils étaient
trop chers toujours dans l'idée de faire
parler lui de faire parler du nom de
citroën cet homme génial a décidé de
fabriquer des auto show avec kool shen
l'aide d'un grand ingénieur instinct et
grèce qui aidera c'est le nom qui est
resté de ces chenilles en caoutchouc
ce qui était tout à fait nouveau et puis
ça a été la création de la croisière
noire et finalement de la croisière
jaune et tout ça a été une époque qui a
coûté très cher à citroën
il a essayé d'en vendre en france à
l'industrie pour remplacer les tracteurs
agricoles 7 et cher les chenilles était
relativement fragile les réparations
presque impossible il n'y a pas eu le
dessus
dans les années 20 et 30 citroën va
aller d'invention en inventions à tous
les niveaux il est par exemple
le premier a édité des revues techniques
sur ces modèles concernant ces véhicules
andré citroën toujours à la recherche
d'un meilleur confort adopte en 1932 un
brevet français vendus à chrysler le
moteur flottant qui consiste à monter la
mécanique sur silène bloc bien avant en
1925 il décide de renforcer la sécurité
de l'habitacle et utilise la coque tout
acier auparavant la carrosserie était
constitué d'une structure en bois à
panneaux de tôle qui ne pouvait résister
à aucun choc
l'utilisation exclusive d'acier
constitue alors une grande innovation
pour la sécurité routière
[Musique]
poursuivant dans ce sens la marque
citroën lance en 1932 avec la nouvelle
gamme rosalie la carrosserie monopièce
il ne s'agit pas encore d'une structure
véritablement monocoque mais l'ensemble
des panneaux latéraux sont pressés d'une
seule pièce ce qui constitue une
formidable innovation dans le domaine de
l'emboutissage la rigidité de la
carrosserie s'en trouve évidemment
accrue et citroën n'hésitent pas à
effectuer des démonstrations
spectaculaires pour le prouver
[Musique]
de telle invention s'accompagne
logiquement de coûts de production plus
élevés les techniques de fabrication et
les machines outils étant de plus en
plus perfectionnés malgré le succès
considérable de ces automobiles andré
citroën sans dette d'année en année pour
améliorer sans cesse les effets de la
crise économique de 1929 commence
néanmoins à avoir des répercussions
dramatiques sur l'ensemble de
l'industrie en 1932 la production chute
de moitié et citroën est contraint de
licencier massivement et d'effectuer des
contrôles draconiens sur les finances ce
qui n'empêche pas d'agrandir à grands
frais le site de javel en 1933
emporté par un enthousiasme et une
mégalomanie aveugle continuellement
animé par l' envie d'aller toujours plus
loin dans l'innovation est d'avoir
plusieurs longueurs d'avancé sur la
concurrence
citroën lance en 1933 contre l'avis des
financiers l'étude d'une automobile
révolutionnaire a toutefois nui citroën
pensait déjà depuis un moment faire une
traction avant
et voilà que lefebvre arrive avec ce
projet ça l'accord a été conclu tout de
suite et un an après vous me suivez bien
de mars 1933 mars 1934
l'attraction était finie elle roulait et
elle était présenté aux concessionnaires
en partant de zéro
aucune autre pièce d'aucun autre modèle
de citroën avait été réutilisés fonds
seraient incapables de faire en partant
de zéro
une voiture aussi révolutionnaire que
celle là on serait incapable de le faire
maintenant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tout va bien la promenade continuer
je
alors cette traction avant avait une
carrosserie coque ce qui était nouveau
elle avait un plancher plat lis donc
aérodynamique
elle avait d'une suspension par bordeaux
torsion elle avait un tableau de bord
nouveau les vitesses sur la planche de
bord à l'avant de cette coque
il y avait quatre broches avec quatre
boulons et on pouvait enlever le mans en
enlevant les quatre boulons enlever tout
le train avant d'un bloc le moteur la
boîte de vitesses les cieux l'ayroule
radiateur tous sortaient d'un bloc comme
un tiroir et puis et puis et puis ça a
été le succès de la traction avant
et
m
andré citroën ne connaîtra pourtant pas
le succès considérable de sa traction
avant rongé par un cancer usé
psychologiquement il décède le 3 juillet
1935 à l'âge de 57 ans laissant derrière
lui une oeuvre considérable pas
seulement liée à l'histoire de
l'automobile
il est mort ruiné parce que il a pris
les banquiers de frau et il existe un
peu mégalo ça va avec deux personnages
donc il n'a jamais accepté d'être les
buteurs des banques et de devoirs tous
les lundis matin comme tous les
présidents y compris celles
d'automobiles aller faire leurs courses
verte devant les banquiers il est même
allé jusqu'à créer sa propre banque
en faisant ses propres crédits parce
qu'il a aussi inventé le crédit
automobile et la l'intelligentzia de la
banque s'est braquée contre lui et l'a
mis en faillite mais d'une feuille
d'ailleurs qui qui était à la limite de
la tolérance tolérable puisque à trois
mois après alizé la soudure
il avait pris du retard sur le lancement
de la traction si l'attraction était
arrivée la maison se redressait elle
s'est redressée d'ailleurs quelques mois
après lui je pense qu'un bon citoyen a
tout inventé de la publicité de la
publicité mode est certain il est arrivé
à l'âge de la réclame c'était encore du
beau du bon du bonnet et avec cet esprit
d'innovation mais aussi d'aventuriers et
qui l'inventé il a défriché tous ceux
qui étaient autour de la publicité
d'abord les croisières qui l'ont rendus
célèbre petit et des véritables
opérations publicité la visite cuisine
lindbergh lui-même qui s'est dirigé
grâce à l'auto refn qui a atterri grâce
à la tour eiffel et citroën sur la terre
elle est venue à cause de ça parce qu'il
avait refusé
mais comme il a estimé que
la tour eiffel illuminée par citoyen lui
avait sauvé la vie il a accepté de venir
inaugurer l'usiné en extraordinaire et
puis il a inventé ce qui fait florès
encore aujourd'hui les essais l'avait
prévu le principe de caravanes qui
faisaient le tour de france de toutes
ces concessions et qui pour la première
fois
permettez décès les voitures qui bon 70
ans et était une révolution en 1922
andré citroën va lancer ses fameux raid
à travers l'afrique et l'asie la
traversée du sahara en 1922 et 1923 puis
la fameuse croisière noire en 1924 et
1925 vont constituer un fantastique défi
technique et humain permettre d'explorer
des terres encore méconnue et apporter à
citroën
une publicité sans précédent
[Musique]
plus emblématiques encore sera la
croisière jaune de 1931 et 1932 avec un
parcours de 12 mille kilomètres à
travers des paysages qui n'avait encore
jamais vu d'automobiles et n'en verront
jamais plus la syrie l'irak
l'afghanistan l'inde verront passer la
colonne de citroën les autos chenille
passeront même à travers les plus hauts
sommets du thivet bien qu'il ait fallu
parfois les démonter pièce par pièce
puis ce seront les vents de sable du
désert de gobi qui attendront les
aventuriers français
l'arrivée triomphale à pékin consacrera
l'endurance des mécaniques citroën douze
des treize autochenille ayant pris le
départ
franchissant les portes de la capitale
chinoise
[Musique]
les films réalisés sur ces croisières
feront le tour du monde
faisant du nom citroën un synonyme
d'avant garde et de défis
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en 1925 andré citroën aura une autre
idée pour faire connaître sa marque
toujours grandiloquent il n'hésitera pas
en effet à investir toute la hauteur de
la tour eiffel pour y installer son nom
en lettres de feu des milliers
d'ampoulés de mètres de câbles
électriques seront nécessaires pour
parvenir à créer cette publicité géante
pour mener à bien l'installation fera
appel à des voltigeurs trapézistes et
autres cascadeur capable de travailler à
plusieurs dizaines de mètres du sol sans
connaître le vertige on remarquera
d'ailleurs sur ces images qu'aucun d'eux
ne porte de baudriers ou de câbles de
sécurité
[Musique]
ans
à
[Applaudissements]
le luy chevaux citroën de série petite
rosalie a parcouru sur l'autodrome de
montlhéry à plus de 93 de moyenne 300
mille kilomètres en 130 4 jours ce qui
représente près des quatre cinquièmes de
la distance de la terre à la lune jamais
voiture au monde n'avait approcher une
telle performance
les huit chevaux citoyenne petite
rosalie a été acheté chez un
concessionnaire parisien de la marque
par la société d huile yako et mise en
piste par l le 15 mars 1933
la voici au 62e jour de sa ronde qui
jusqu'àlors s'est déroulée sans histoire
à cette date elle commence à établir de
nouveaux records du monde puisqu'elle
vient d'atteindre 140 mille kilomètres
et de surpasser par conséquent l'exploit
de son aîné voici devant la ligne de
départ le poste de contrôle où se
tiennent en permanence jour et nuit les
commissaires techniques des
chronométreurs officiels de la sienne la
tentative est contrôlée d'une façon
permanente par les commissaires
techniques de l'automobile club de
france qui va est impitoyablement à la
stricte application des règlements
internationaux
mais voici l'heure du ravitaillement de
la voiture celui ci ne peut
naturellement s'effectuer qu'en présence
même d'un commissaire régulièrement
toutes les cinq heures la voiture fait
son plein d'essence et éventuellement
d'huile et d'eau c'est aussi à ce moment
que s'effectue le changement de pilote
le signal d'arrêt est donné voici bons
échos qui va relayer au volant de la
vaillante petite voiture son camarade
justin marchand les ravitaillements sont
effectués à une allure accord car les
temps d'arrêt quels que soient leur
cause ne sont en aucun cas neutraliser
leur durée compte dans le temps total du
parcours de la performante
la pompe à essence un débit beaucoup
trop lent et remplacé par un réservoir
dans lequel le carburant est maintenu
sous forte pression
grâce à une bouteille d'air comprimé le
plein d'huile est effectué sous la
surveillance du commissaire il replonge
ensuite l'orifice de remplissage du
moteur
toujours sous ses yeux on procède à la
vérification de la pression des pneus et
le cas échéant aux quelques travaux
d'entretien autorisée qui ne peuvent
être effectuée qu'au poste de
ravitaillement et avec les seuls moyens
du bord
[Musique]
moi
est ce une concurrente étrangère la
forte valentine qui n'est certes pas
d'un modèle des plus récents batel
s'attaquer au record de petite rosalie
non elle vient simplement faire sa
promenade quotidienne pour semer les 120
de sa lanterne tempête qui jalonneront
la nuit le bas côté de la piste
[Musique]
et la vente se poursuit inlassablement
et juin succède toujours et les records
27 juillet petite rosalie ayant parcouru
la formidable distance de 300 mille
kilomètres en 130 4 jours monsieur
citroën décidé de l'arrêter avant que
l'usure ou un accident fortuit de la
mettre hors de course
désirant que l'examen détaillé de ces
divers organes permettent de faire le
point des progrès accomplis en vue de
préparer les progrès à venir
[Musique]
en quelques mots monsieur citera il
remercie tous ceux qui ont collaboré à
cette extraordinaire performance tout
particulièrement monsieur dintilhac
administrateur délégué de la société d
huile yako en moteur de la tentative et
la merveilleuse équipe de pilotes
conduite par césar marchand l'homme des
records du monde afin de stimuler les
recherches des ingénieurs en vue de
nouveaux progrès à réaliser
monsieur citroën termine son allocution
en annonçant qu'il vient de décider
d'offrir un prix de 3 millions aux
constructeurs français ou étrangers qui
avant le 1er janvier 1935 réalisera le
premier avec une voiture de sa
fabrication
une performance meilleure que celle
établie par petite rosalie à la fin du
lunch qui termine la manifestation petit
rosalie c'est un dernier tour de piste
piloté par monsieur andré citroën lui
même
vous
[Musique]
mais tout n'était pas fini pour petite
rosalie son capot est soigneusement
plombé par un commissaire
[Musique]
puis elle quitte l'autodrome pour se
rendre au laboratoire de l'acf toujours
suivi de ces contrôleurs
le directeur du laboratoire monsieur lui
mais vérifie lui même la cylindrée de
petites roses a mis quelques jours après
il se rend aux usines citroën pour
choisir au hasard sur la chaîne de
montage un chat séduit chevaux afin de
s'assurer par examen comparatif des
organes des deux châssis que petite
rosalie est bien de série
[Musique]
toutes les cotes des pièces sont
comparés
leur identité est encore contrôlée par
la compta raison de leur poids
[Musique]
où
ces opérations terminées les pièces de
chaque châssis sont enfermés dans deux
caisses soigneusement repérer et plombé
[Musique]
elles sont transportées au laboratoire
des arts et métiers
une commission composée des plus
éminentes personnalités scientifiques
françaises examinent en détails les
pièces d'homologues et constate la
parfaite identité au point de vue
chimique et métal la graphie petite
remontée fini sa carrière sur le stand
du salon de l'automobile
la foule va la demi heure puis elle puis
transféré au palais des expositions
citroën place de l'europe avec ses
devancières
s il avait fallu trente ans à
l'industrie automobile pour porter le
record du monde de distance à 50 mille
km2 en suffire aux usines citroën pour
les levées progressivement à 300 mille
kilomètres et cela avec des voitures
strictement de série aucune marque au
monde ne peut produire un tel témoignage
de la qualité de fabrication
[Musique]
raids internationaux record publicité
andré citroën aura révolutionné les
méthodes de communication des grandes
entreprises
après sa mort il faudra attendre la fin
des années 50 et l'arrivée du studio
delpire pour retrouver des publicités
citroën novatrice dans les années 70 la
collaboration avec le publiciste jacques
séguéla perpétuera une certaines
innovations dans ce domaine
[Musique]
et à projets citroën par le tour du
monde puisque c'est eux qui m'avait
permis de populariser mans tout le monde
c'était qui m'ont fait écrire mon
premier livre c'est grâce à lui que je
suis rentré un match c'est eux qui vont
faire rentrer à paris match où je
faisais d'ailleurs j'ai fait dès le
lancement dans match de la série x et de
beaucoup de modèles citroën
et puis c'est ensuite qu'ils m'ont fait
rentrer dans la publicité chez delpire
puis j'ai créé mon agence del firme a
d'ailleurs vendu la sienne à ce moment
là et c'est comme ça que je suis entré
directement sur le budget site web pour
une fois en main propre c'est parti de
là était toujours au niveau de la marque
il partira avec savignac puis ensuite
avec jean paul goude iration et tout ce
qui s'est passé par la suite
[Musique]
la capacité à produire des publicités
originales étaient bien évidemment
renforcée par le fait que les citroën
étaient des autos d'avant garde
après guerre la deux chevaux puis la ds
vont en effet maintenir avec brio la
politique d'innovation de la marque
française
[Musique]
à bari le 35e salon de l'automobile a
été inaugurée par monsieur vincent
auriol président de la république dans
la première visite a été pour ceux qui
comme fram est sans devenu par leurs
luxueuses conception de la carrosserie
les grands couturiers de la voiture il
est loin le temps où le poète parlait de
ces machines qui permettait d'absorber
en un jour autant de paysages de ciel et
de spectacles qu'on en absorber d'autres
fois au cours de toute une vie le temps
où loin des remises et des gares loin
des ateliers secourable l'automobiliste
était à la merci des caprices d'une
force mystérieuse qui nous laisse est
inquiet sur l'avenir de la géniale
découverte de l'homme
une véritable révolution a été provoqué
dans le domaine du véhicule économique
par citroën qui présente un modèle de
conception pour le moins originale
peut-être verrons-nous demain ces
véhicules circulaient sur nous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]